near the turn of this century scientists
jörg Steinhauser had a problem he was
fascinated by the question why do some
belly buttons collect more lint than
others but no one knew the answer so for
three years he collected his own
bellybutton lint to find out and after
interviewing friends and analyzing 503
of his own samples Steinhauser
discovered the culprit stomach hair it
scratches off tiny t-shirt fibers and
directs them towards the belly button so
that might be one mystery solved
but lint isn't the only thing inside
these bizarre human crevices your belly
button is a scar your very first one it
forms when a doctor snips your umbilical
cord and depending on how it heals you
could have an Audi or more likely on any
and innies are ripe for colonization not
only by lint hair and dead skin cells
but also by bacteria in one study 60
volunteers swab their belly buttons
researchers then analyzed the samples
and found more than 2,300 kinds of
bacteria that's an average of 67
different kinds per bellybutton now many
of those microbes aren't unique to belly
buttons like Staphylococcus which can
lead to staph infections it shows up in
noses throats hair and yes even belly
buttons but the researchers also
discovered other bacteria never before
seen on human skin like ma Ramona's
which scientists had previously only
seen in the ocean and they even found
bacteria that chefs used to make cheese
and yes somebody did exactly that
she grew the bellybutton bacteria in a
petri dish and then added it to milk
sure enough after a few hours the milk
curdled into cheese belly button breathe
anyone now for the most part the
microbes in your navel are harmless
in fact recent studies suggest that
bacteria on your body may strengthen
your skin's defense system but if you
never clean your belly button they'll
grow unencumbered and that can be a
problem the best case scenario is that
your belly button will start to smell
when common navel microbes like
corynebacterium build up they emit
pungent odors similar to body odor but
the worst case is that your navel will
get infected not just by staff but also
by microbes that cause strep throat and
yeast infections that's right you can
get a yeast infection in your belly
button which can lead to itching and
redness and cause a clear or off-white
discharge to leak out which almost looks
like cottage cheese so how does that
cheese sound now while microbes colonize
your belly button from the outside there
could also be an invader from the inside
we're talking about belly button hernias
in the womb the umbilical cord runs from
your mom to you passing through an
opening in your abdominal muscles
normally that opening seals up after
you're born but in some cases it never
really closes all the way this can allow
internal organs to slip through creating
a bulge behind your belly button navel
hernias affect as many as one in five
newborns in the US but they're rarely
life-threatening and are far less common
in adults in fact as long as you rinse
your belly button with warm soapy water
once a week the worst you'll have to put
up with is a little fluff